according to News Buster's a thing in
the last three months broadcast news
coverage of Donald Trump was 91%
negative which is shocking there was
nine percent positive I didn't see it
I've seen more favorable coverage of
scurvy according to the media Research
Center Trump's got more airtime in his
first 224 days in office than Obama did
in his last two years on the job which
makes sense Trump's a one-man band
generating money and outrage or rather
money for the outraged like and him
MSNBC's joy read in an interview she
stated I've said to people that this is
probably the greatest time to be a
journalist and the worst time to be a
human oh dear dear let's think about
that read a journalist said that this is
probably the worst time to be a human
where did you go to school
I kind of remember reading about the
dark ages the Black Death the Mongols
Nazi concentration camps the atrocities
of the Aztecs the famine in Ukraine the
Khmer Rouge the Western Front during
World War one Japanese prison camps in
World War two the Soviet Union
remember Siberia you get the picture
does joy as she forgets and insults
hundreds of millions who died in the
worst times ever
but hey hysteria pays the bills but I
can say safely that the best time to be
human is right now the statistics show
at far less poverty decline in worldwide
violence vast improvements in a gene
medicine and technology but I guess you
can't say that when you live in a
left-wing bubble where ninety one
percent is every single person you know
and everyone else you believe is Hitler
I don't know Kimberly ninety-one percent
negative that seems a little low to me I
think it's about 98 percent bump it up
yeah
plus or minus 3% margin of 801 percent
if you get back yeah I don't know it's
quite interesting so um here's the
problem I think that the media obviously
is very fixated on President Trump and
they're going to harbor and sort of like
hype on anything that they feel is gonna
be negative publicity press etc but he
has a bad a fractured relationship with
them right I mean he does so for
whatever reason you want to blame his
side or blame the media side it's a it's
a relationship that is in dire need of
repair so when you see something like
this they say okay well this is to be
expected look at this this is what we've
been telling you and it reinforces their
beliefs about him and what they would
like to make sure that gets you know put
forward by everybody the narrative that
they embrace and enjoy and believe in
part of their ideology you know one as
bad as you think Donald Trump is and I
know you think he's bad 91% that is
that's what you call media bias correct
you got to admit I don't know if it's
media bias by the way I was listening to
what you said in there and I was just
taken by because I thought you were
right I mean you convinced me through
all the things that happen in history
say oh this is the worst thing to be a
lie
it's so disappointing for Democrats and
I think some Republicans if you look at
the opinion polls to have Trump in the
White House but to say this is the worst
time to be alive yeah that's a little
much a stretch thank you thank you Katie
yeah so but I would say this I think a
Trump dominates the news media and the
coverage in a way we have never seen
yeah I just don't think there's ever
been a president who's as media friendly
or hostile Harvey because he's fighting
the press he tweets out you know
slamming CNN and all the rest fake news
bag reporters he goes in so there's a
lot of that
the second thing to say is he hasn't had
a lot of success if you think about the
Russia scandal Obamacare repeal what
happened in Charlottesville the problems
ongoing problems with North Korea that
we'll discuss later in the show and then
a success don't you think what North
Korea we're seeing a success we're
seeing hey let's play all right
I'm all for it to be a success I just
don't think it's a success as yet that's
all I'm saying so I think a lot of that
generates news coverage that you could
take as negative what struck me about
this report was it said 90% of maybe at
80 and 80 or 90% of the voices talking
about Trump are from Republicans
Republicans are pretty critical I think
Steve Banta said he thinks the GOP
establishment sought to get Donald Trump
and it may be reflected in the news
coverage uh-uh
well Jesse what do you make of all of
this what do you make of this poll what
do you think of Juan's tie there are
many reasons that the press is so
hostile to the president it's not just
because they're liberal one he's a
threat to their power because he uses
Twitter and he goes over their head to
they're bitter because they called the
election all wrong 3 they don't have the
prestige of access to the White House
that they would have had under Hillary
for they are now the tip of the spear
because the Democrats in Washington have
no power so they have to be the attack
dogs and then finally they can't afford
to have president Trump be successful if
he is successful and redraws the map
electoral e that the Democrats are shut
out of power for a very long time
and I think it's very disrespectful for
the mainstream media to treat 40% of the
country who still has a lot of love and
respect for this president like they
don't even matter the media is wondering
why we're so divided look in the mirror
it's too dismissive right the base is
locked down ninety-eight percent of
people that voted for the president the
primaries still support him 80% of
Republicans still support him he has
positive feelings towards his handling
of the economy and terrorism two major
issues according to his re-election
campaign so look at the accomplishments
a million jobs created wages are up the
stock markets very high ms-13 is getting
kicked out he handled two hurricanes
very smoothly and Isis Isis is being
decimated we haven't had a domestic
terror attack so far knock on wood so
all in all you have Russia
you have Comey and you have
Charlottesville to be fair they were big
stumbling blocks for this President
Obama if you Obama care if you put that
on
balance with all those other
accomplishments there's no way a
fair-minded person can say he deserves
ninety-one percent negative come yes and
you know Dana good point here briefly
about the hurricane coverage I think
that was a turning point in some waves
when people kind of even to say but you
know that's a commander-in-chief well
it's interesting
this was done this poll study was done
in the last three months but it wasn't
done in the last month and actually if
he just took the last week he made a
deal with the Democrats the media should
like that
the hurricane coverage I wrote down was
great he wants he said he wanted to get
rid of daca but actually he wants the
law to pass he said he would sign it he
also his legislative director said today
he's not going to necessarily tie the
funding of the wall to daca so the media
should like that there's fewer leaks so
the White House is running better under
general Kelly
there's winds at the United Nations you
can't deny that economic growth was
revised upward to three percent for the
first time in many moons maybe like five
dozen moons I think the tonight the
president's having a bipartisan dinner
with members of the problem-solvers
caucus so all of these things a year ago
would have been definitely thumbs down
yeah conservative media so now should
the conservative media's like okay well
we're okay with all of that yeah and the
mainstream media you would think would
actually appreciate those things that's
a very good list you just thank you it
was almost as good as Jesse's but half
as long yeah let's switch over to the
point that joy Reid is making I can't
believe that she actually believes it
but what if she does believe that if
you're in that kind of bubble that you
believe that this is the worst time to
be a human have you looked on YouTube
yeah they're out there yeah there are
people like breaking down Nick freaking
out they're in their bubble of ik misery
and discontent and they actually really
believe it I don't think there's a bunch
of fakers out there I think they
actually feel like this is so upsetting
I don't know what's happening what you
know direction to come the country is
going to but guess what they're also a
large number of people that feel like
okay guess what someone's finally
listening to us and embracing the values
that we love and believe in in this
country about the working-class men and
women that have
left behind so there's plenty of things
you know refer back to Jesse's list of
accomplishments and things that are
actually going quite well and if you're
into like the numbers and you're into
jobs and you're into the unemployment
numbers and actually you know
infrastructure and things that are
happening you can say there's a lot
positive to point to but you won't hear
it in the mainstream media echo chamber
which just resonates with sort of this
vitriol for the president and really
will not have that you know they don't
they lack the honesty to actually put
forward what is happening that's
positive so a lot of people out there
think it's all bad because they're not
hearing it depending on what their news
so let me tell you what I hear so today
I'm reading the paper and it says that
median income in the United States in
2016 was the highest in history well
since 1999 right no I think I said in
history yeah okay so I think to myself
Wow good news for the American middle
class but that was 2016 and Donald Trump
was running and this is picking up on
what Kimberly was saying and he was
saying hey so many people being left
behind people are unhappy buddy but I
think wait a minute but we had the
highest median income do you know why
because they knew Trump was winning oh
they knew Trump had a psychological
effect on the wages oh is that what he
had a retro effect I think he plays to
anger and resentment and then people
when you pointed out people say what's
natural I read right now she's doing
that she's playing to anger I don't
think in fact what she said in the
interview was very interesting to me she
said you know Trump supporters watch Fox
News they're unavailable to her she
doesn't believe she can persuade them
right well I think George Bush ran
against Clinton ran against Bush 41 and
said the economy was terrible meanwhile
that economy was on the comeback trail
so you know both parties do it but Trump
will take credit and will want to
improve median income wages - joy Reid
you know it's in the Trump era you know
what it's bad to be a Democrat also bad
to be a member of ms-13 or Isis or
someone that works for CNN I know are
you comparing her to Isis no I just want
to make sure you're not
those things right now are not good
things to be in the tumbler you know
what though I would argue that it's a
good it's a it's a good economic model
you're seeing the success if you look
there are certain people they did really
well being hypercritical of Obama so
what I don't know I can't think of them
offhand but everyone in media is doing
better financially in the era of Trump
right so he's thriving off of the fight
she has with the media and he the good
news for him is that most people don't
actually get their news from the
mainstream media anymore they're getting
it from social media and that actually
for better or worse locks down the base
so I think that if Joey Reid had this
interview to do over again that that's a
line that maybe she said it flippantly
sore like when there was that report
that Donald Trump said the White House
is a real dump I wonder if she actually
cuz I don't believe that he actually
said it or he said it was in jest
she said she often says this she might
say but also so I read that entire
interview with her and I think because I
don't know her at all and I come away
thinking I actually kind of liked her so
she's she grew up in Colorado both
parents were immigrants she was raised
by a single mom but when her dad was
there he was a big right-wing
conservative loves Ronald Reagan her mom
was a left-winger so she has lots of
praise for her single mom that taken her
all over the country to see this great
American country that she loves then but
I also admires that she was a journalist
straight-up journalist in 2004 she was
so against the Iraq war she wrote an
op-ed she got blowback from her
employers about it she worked for a TV
station I think it was down in Florida
and she decided to quit and she started
over her career and went into the
opinion journalism which is where she
sits now at MSNBC and so there's lots of
people can have opinions I think that
one line she'd probably want to take out
of it but she does benefit from being
anti-trump in today's media because she
got a cover story it ended a subject of
our April that'll never happen to any of
us even and she did it after flunking
every history class so I admire that
Dana gave a very fair and accurate
assessment of who she is and where she
came from and her background which I
think it adds a lot to the story I
disagree well what do you know
I disagree at this segment so I mean